fake mug shots knocked off millions and
a horrifying body count you caught the
dramatic dock but did you get the full
story Reckless boozehound to murder For
Hire here's what Netflix left out the
Netflix documentary Murdoch murders a
southern Scandal devotes itself to the
2019 boat crash that killed Mallory
Beach three couples Anthony cook and
Mallory Beach Connor Cook and Millie
Altman and Morgan Doty and Paul Murdock
went out on the Murdoch family boat to a
party they started heading back home
around midnight but despite Paul being
highly intoxicated he wouldn't let
anyone else Drive episode 2 opens just
hours after the crash as Rescuers
frantically search for Mallory the other
passengers except for Mallory's
boyfriend Anthony who remained at the
scene were rushed to the hospital there
while placed in restraints Paul's blood
alcohol level was confirmed to be over
three times the legal limit Morgan's mom
Diane claimed a nurse warned her I'm not
supposed to say this to you but Paul
he's a nasty drunk and you need to get
away from him as fast as you can but
what wasn't mentioned was how Paul was
apparently laughing and hitting on the
nurses according to the HBO docu-series
Low Country the Murdoch Dynasty Paul's
behavior in the hospital was shocking he
appeared unfazed by the tragedy and was
seemingly unconcerned about his missing
friend and the consequences that awaited
him the Netflix doc details the many
ways in which Alec Murdoch reportedly
tried to get his son's friend Conor to
be named as the driver of the boat
rather than Paul this ranges from
instructing the kids not to answer
questions and say they don't know who's
driving the boat to claiming to legally
represent them all to even contacting
Connor's parents and so that night I'm
worried about funding my child and
they're worried about how they're gonna
cover up
Paul driving what the series doesn't
mention is that Alec is said to have
recommended attorney Corey Fleming for
Connor and his family but Corey Fleming
is a good friend and former college
roommate of Alex a connection that the
Cook family was unaware of it would
surely be a conflict of interest for
someone closely tied to the murdochs to
represent the person Alec wanted to take
the blame Fleming would later be
indicted as a co-conspirator in Alex
many Financial crimes he already had the
plan in motion and we fell for it
it was two months after the deaths of
Mallory Beach when Paul Murdoch was
charged with three felonies one count of
driving a water vehicle Under the
Influence resulting in death and two
counts of boating Under the Influence
resulting in great bodily injury but
while the Netflix stock provides
evidence of various parties questioning
why Paul hadn't been booked into jail
yet it doesn't make clear that this
actually never happened even after
Paul's indictment it took an additional
month before the charges were brought up
there are statements from his friends
parents about how he was never
handcuffed Mallory's mother even
recounts how his mug shot was taken of
him in a nice shirt and while all of
that is true it's shocking to discover
that Paul never even set foot in the
police station he was never booked at
all and that mugshot it was taken
against a wall outside the courtroom
another way Paul was apparently given
what's referred to as the quote
gentleman's treatment is that the judge
who said his bond denied the
prosecution's request for Paul to wear
an alcohol monitor given that Paul was
charged with three felonies committed
while Under the Influence this was seen
by many as gross neglect of Duty it was
even brought up on Twitter using the
hashtag South's good old boy system he
never went behind bars he never had
handcuffs never wore the orange suit not
only did Paul get sent home to wait
indefinitely for a criminal trial but he
reportedly continued to drink and party
like nothing ever happened Paul's former
girlfriend Morgan says she saw Snapchat
stories and other social media posts of
people still partying with Paul a
monitor which the Netflix series never
addresses would have at the very least
ensured that this underage teen was not
continuing to abuse alcohol illegally
it's not until episode 2 of the Netflix
series that the main events are
discussed in detail this show provides
the audio of the 911 call Alec made as
well as Alex timeline of his movements
that night but it leaves out significant
details reported problems in the
Murdoch's marriage are noted as are the
rumors that Maggie had hired a forensic
accountant and maybe even met with a
divorce attorney but the episode doesn't
reveal that Maggie wasn't living at the
Moselle house at the time instead she
had been staying at their beach house in
Edisto far from Alec so why was she at
Mozelle the HBO doc Low Country explains
that Maggie had been living at the beach
house but that on June 7th Alec texted
her asking to meet up she apparently
even discussed the worrying texts with
her sister saying Alec was quote up to
something at the trial Maggie's sister
testified that Alex's father was
hospitalized and that Alec claimed his
dad needed Maggie's support after
hearing this she agreed to meet him at
the Moselle house she was killed that
night
Netflix covers how the survivors of the
2019 boat crash were each asked to
provide an alibi for the night of the
murder and how they were all cleared of
Suspicion but even so the crash was
continually linked to the murders by
many different sources I think this may
very well be related to the death of
Mallory Beach what was the motivation
other than anger or Revenge but in the
2020 episode Murdoch family murders it
becomes clear why people initially
assumed that these two events would be
related Alec there's extensive footage
from Alec at the murder scene in which
he frequently mentions the boat crash
and claims it's the reason his wife and
son are dead the episode also shows the
very first interview Alec gave to state
law enforcement he again brings up the
crash in connection with the murders
saying that Paul had been threatened and
targeted then when Alec took the stand
on February 23 2021 his attorney played
the 9-1-1 call in which Alec named the
threats regarding the crash as the
motive appearing to dictate The
Narrative he laments
[Music]
according to the Netflix doc two weeks
into investigating the murders of Paul
and Maggie Murdoch state law enforcement
reopened the case of Steven Smith's
death killed in 2015 19 year old Smith
was found lying in the middle of a road
with head injuries while Alex oldest son
Buster Murdoch was mentioned in
connection with the case never LED
anywhere Steven's death was labeled a
hit and run and the case was closed this
is not a wreck
is the murder but what the HBO doc
reveals is that the only reason the
coroner called it a hit and run is
because Smith's body was found in the
road State Police are said to have found
the death suspicious for various reasons
the complete lack of glass or debris at
the crime scene the odd position of the
body and the lack of injury anywhere
else on his person the Netflix show
fails to mention that the coroner
seemingly ignored all this evidence yes
there's an indication that the
investigation was rushed or covered up
on behalf of the Murdoch's but the HBO
version actually backs this up with a
statement from Steven Smith's mother
Sandy Smith said that the morning
Steven's body was found Alex oldest
brother offered to represent the family
and then before the sheriff came
in Randy Murdock was calling on
September 4th 2021 three months after
the murders of Maggie and Paul Alec
Murdock called 9-1-1 again this time he
said he'd been shot in the head by an
unknown man who stopped to help him
change his tire the Netflix miniseries
addresses the particulars of this case
but it leaves out some crucial
information Alex injury is listed in the
police report as a superficial gunshot
wound to the head which would seem to
corroborate Alex story but a guest on
2020 said that the medical report
revealed the wounds weren't from a
gunshot at all instead they were likely
due to a fall another item left out of
the Netflix series is how there were 10
shell casings found at the scene which
didn't add up to Alex story at all it
was soon revealed that Alec had asked
his cousin Curtis Eddie Smith to shoot
him Smith confirmed to 2020 that the
request was made but that he never hurt
Alec he said I need you to kill me I
said yeah
and I started drawn up in the air on
September 6 2021 Alec Murdock announced
that he was resigning from his law firm
and entering rehab he would later reveal
an opioid addiction but the firm swiftly
contradicted this story The Law Firm was
founded in 1910 by Randolph Murdoch
senior Alex great grandfather Netflix
mentions the trip to rehab briefly but
2020 goes into much more detail if
anyone wants to see the face of what
opioid addiction does you're looking at
mere hours after Alex statement about
entering rehab The Firm released its own
statement saying that Murdoch didn't
resign as he claims instead he was asked
to leave on September 3rd the day before
his bizarre roadside shooting because he
had misappropriated funds from clients
and the firm alike according to 2020
Alec was briefly removed from rehab to
be charged in the shooting hoax he was
then charged with the theft of the
Satterfield settlement the day Alec left
rehab he was charged with the murders of
his wife and son what the Netflix doc
does doesn't get into is just how many
Financial crimes Alec Murdock has been
accused of the memo from the law firm
stating he had been misappropriating
funds opened the door to dozens of
incidents where Alec defrauded his
clients or embezzled money from his firm
all in it totaled millions of dollars a
whopping 99 charges have been filed
related to these findings but the crimes
also seemingly provide a motive for the
deaths of Paul and Maggie Paul's boating
accident in 2019 had yet to go to trial
but a civil case against him on behalf
of the beach family was progressing a
hearing was scheduled for June 10th just
three days after Paul and Maggie were
murdered that hearing was to request an
accounting of the family's Financial
records which Alec presumably didn't
want to release Beech family attorney
Mark Tinsley told 2020 that after the
murders the hearing was indefinitely
canceled and if Maggie was also filing
for divorce then Alex finances would
have been scrutinized in that scenario
as well
one of the most egregious of Alec
Murdoch's Financial crimes is the one
perpetrated against the family of his
former housekeeper Gloria Satterfield
the Netflix series covers satterfield's
long relationship with the murdochs as
well as her death in 2018. Satterfield
reportedly fell and hit her head on
brick steps at the house but the
inconsistency in the accounting of the
incident was troubling Alec claimed to
be at the scene talking to Gloria
claiming she told him the dogs tripped
her but during the 911 call Paul and
Maggie's voices are evident but Alex is
not witness statements also reveal that
Alec wasn't there at the time of the
fall and that Gloria never regained
Consciousness he said I want to make
sure the boys are taken care of
Netflix doc also touches on the plan
Alec devised to sue himself in order to
collect from the insurance company for
glorious sons and his ultimate betrayal
in taking the entire 4.3 million dollars
for himself but what it leaves out is
the ending to this tragic tale possibly
because filming had wrapped thankfully
the Satterfield Sons were awarded over
7.5 million dollars in settlements from
Murdoch and his co-conspirators
Netflix had their Series in the can
before the trial of Alec Murdoch began
and some damning evidence from the
courtroom is missing from the dock as
noted by 2020 one of the most powerful
exhibits shown to the jury was a
timeline the prosecution's report
included GPS data steps data and second
by second records of all calls and texts
between the parties Alex placed his
9-1-1 call just 19 seconds after he
arrived at the dog kennels as the
prosecution pointed out this wouldn't
have been enough time to check the
pulses of his wife and son whose bodies
were 30 feet apart before he called for
help as he initially claimed other
evidence came from Paul Murdoch's phone
one video showed Alec in different
clothes than he was wearing when police
arrived and in a second video Paul had
taken of a dog at the kennels just
minutes before his death Maggie and Alec
can be heard talking in the background
voiding Alex Alibi the state versus
Richard Alexander Murdoch defendant
indictment for murder verdict guilty
jurors needed only 45 minutes to Victor
Alec Murdock on both counts the next day
he was sentenced to two life sentences
without the possibility of parole
foreign